on a les bons soirs
canal+ comédie laurent baffie europe 2 1
laurent au loin
alain tu collectionnes et rob les
aventures et on peut dire les nikos
était dite et qui pourrait passer mais
tu n'es pas là pour parler de ça c'est
ta vie privée je te laisse entre les
mains de thierry d'accord alors on va
d'abord on va parler de ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui en terme de deux
caritatif en terme d'art et avant je
vais quand même raconter votre vie dont
vous êtes libanaise chrétienne
né à beyrouth et vous aviez 17 18 ans
quand la guerre du liban a éclaté vous
êtes venu en france d'abord dans le sud
de la france et en 76
vous vous retrouvez à paris à la
sorbonne
sans beaucoup d'argent la prostitution
une chambre de bonne non chauffée avec
un lavabo un lit où travaille d'abord
dans une pizzeria ça c'est un destin un
champignon absolument absolument
extraordinaire je serai dans une
pizzeria et ensuite nous en resterons
libanais de huit heures du soir à 3
heures du matin et le matin fallait
quand même prendre le métro à 7 heures
pour être en cours à 8 heures donc ça
c'est ces courageux vos parents vous
envoie 300 francs par mois et au resto
dans le resto vous gagnez qui ont
maintenant gagné rien au cannet en
faisait que le pourvoir oui oui c'est
signé ouais ça qu'on les traite alors
vous aviez du succès avec les hommes
parce que c'est une très jolie femme et
vous avez du succès avec les hommes
depuis l'âge de 14 ans déjà sur la plage
à beyrouth vous apercevez qu'il faut
qu'ils vous regardent et est en fait
vous n'aviez aucune envie d'épouser un
étudiant du
du même âge vous avez pas envie de
travailler 20 ans pour acheter une
maison à la fin c'est ça c'est une vie
qui vous tentez pas me sais pas j'avais
absolument aucune envie de me marier
tout court voilà tout ce que je voulais
c'est beau c'est travailler des lycées
mon bac ou ma maîtrise et travailler
pour pour soutenir et se souvenir aux
besoins de ma famille je voulais c'est
arrivé tout à fait par hasard vous
saviez pas que vous alliez épouser un
homme qui allait devenir l'un des hommes
les plus riches du monde pour la 10ème
fortunes du monde un soir vous voyez un
homme entré dans le restaurant libanais
vous travaillez attassi avec une fille
blonde avec lui vous discuté un peu
comme vous par les arabes ils vous
demandent ce que ce que vous faites là
et cetera nous comprend rien attention
vous étiez vous étiez quoi la caisse
vous étiez faisiez quoi dans treize
tours tout est une alliance aussi comme
j'étais comme j'étais bon en maths donc
je tenais les comptes dessus du
restaurant
je servais quand il avait besoin de
services et puis à la fin quand tout le
monde partait on faisait un peu la fête
parce qu'on était tellement crevé on
avait tellement travaillé donc les
maintient aussi à la sorbonne à 8 heures
du matin quand même
j'étais toujours toujours à l'heure plus
maintenant vous êtes courageux alors
donc un soin vous rencontrer cet homme
le lendemain il revient mais sans la
blonde non le lendemain il revient
encore avec la blonde c'est le le
surlendemain c'est le surlendemain qui
revient s'enlaçant la blonde et puis
après il se met à venir tous les jours
tous les jours pendant deux semaines
presse albert
il était accro le mec alors il avait 38
ans saoudien musulmans pour vous ça
représentait la sécurité effectivement
c'est un homme qui est elle même s'il
n'est pas encore très très riche c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui était déjà dans
le monde des affaires non si si il était
dans le monde et à faire justement il
était en france parce que il signait son
premier contrat très important et
comprenez pas la langue française et moi
je la maîtrise est assez bien et c'est
là que je pense qu'il m'a fait confiance
parce que c'est lui c'était moi qui
avait traduit son premier contrat est ce
que cet homme vous l'avez aimée est-ce
que ça a été le coup de foudre comme
dans la chanson love at first sight
ou est-ce qu'au contraire vous vous
dites je vais apprendre à l'aimer
l'amour ça se construit c'est pas
quelque chose qui finalement sa force de
vivre qu'on finit par s'aimer ou alors
simplement il ressemblait à omar sharif
vous avez craqué du tout de suite
c'était le coup de foudre c'est à dire
que j'étais absolument fasciné par les
il est et il était très intéressant et
toi très intéressé il ressemble en
revanche a réussit là alors il vous
emmène en week-end à londres
1 vous aviez vous connaissiez déroute
connaissiez marseille aix paris et c'est
tout donc là vous découvrez londres et
vous mettez à la doré a cessé alors pour
le mariage évidemment là ça commence
vous commandez une robe c'est jean-louis
chez la maison et objet de perdre 10
kilos pour rentrer dedans nouri si
c'était le modèle mais bon oui c'était
c'était le modèle et puis elles sont
toutes venues que vous savez les
marqueurs et moi je pensais baguette
chocolat et le beurre tous les matins le
régime pendant presque 3 4 semaines pour
pouvoir entrer dans le modèle parce
qu'il n'avait pas le temps de me refaire
une autre
c'était très dur ce mariage là ça
commence et c'est actuellement c'est
très très mal excusez moi
vous trouvez en arabie saoudite dans un
palais alors je sais pas si c'est le bon
chiffre de 30 mille mètres carrés quand
je suis arrivé c'était pas un palais
c'était une maison que je devais tout
fait main et puis c'est devenu papa et
je pense qu'un pavé sans une princesse
il fallait la française donc c'est
devenu on l'a fait ensemble quoi pendant
trois ans la mauritanie faisait 1
millions par là on dépense est passée
par là c'est ce que c'est là ça s'est
passé doucement tranquillement c'est pas
ça se gagne 3000 mètres carrés
la personne s'est beaucoup beaucoup
calmé son immeuble alors oui quand même
volé au salon il ya la métro fléchage ne
faut pas tirer pas de métro mais il y
avait un train aux noms qui me l'a
envoyé et d'un petit train pour le
palais si j'étais assez bien quinze
jours après votre votre arrivée donc là
bas
lui s'en va genève en voyage d'affaires
un papa est en voyage d'affaires
sans vous alors il part il vous dit
qu'il s'en va pour une semaine il
revient à un mois après il voulait
seulement deux mois 20 chérie je t'ai
jamais fait des trucs comme ça c'est
toujours mettre le cadreur non
c'est pas le cas lors ces dames bande de
petite [ __ ]
bon alors donc oui il s'en va deux mois
alors que vous dis qui par une semaine
c'est vrai que c'est pas terrible quoi
et alors vous quand vous êtes présenté à
la famille vous aviez fait un repas on
avait fait tout seul de vos de vaublanc
chemin de fait un repas et quand vous
mettez à table tout le monde serait ce
parce qu'ils avaient fini de cette
expérience est je pense la plus
difficile parce que d'abord c'était la
première où il fallait connaître tout le
monde espère connaître et c'était un
grand choc parce que là je me sentais
pour la première fois de ma vie alors
que j'étais étudiant j'ai voyagé j'ai
fait des diop est tout seul
seul et boudinée dans cette petite
phrase sans cette petite robe jean louis
cher et alors quand vous dites
d'ailleurs pendant presque six mois j'ai
moi j'ai mangé mes larmes quoi lui ces
voyages se multiplient je la fais courte
parce que sinon ces voyages se
multiplier les rumeurs sur les rumeurs
se répandent est une bonne amie a
toujours des bonnes copines dans ce cas
là une bonne amie libanaise qui vous dit
que votre mari à une affaire avec une
femme à beyrouth
et alors là ça se faut connaître les
traditions dans ces pays là c'est
l'anniversaire de vos sept ans de
mariage
vous attendez le retour de votre mari
qui étaient encore partis en voyage
pendant deux mois décidément c'était une
habitude
et quand il revient et vous annonce qui
va se marier cet encart difficile dans
les coûts cap difficile c'est connu le
soir de l'anniversaire même avec un
gâteau et j'avais ce joli gâteau et
j'attendais j'attendais c'était pour
home annonce que moi
mon mari allait se marier parce qu'il
fallait c'était la tradition après un
certain temps c'est à dire si le mari ne
prouve pas qu'il peut moi je dis rien
cette correction exemplaire mais
j'aurais pu dire quoi il est avec la
même femme pendant sept ans et c'est pas
ça veut dire qu'il faut vous n'aurez
qu'une seule femme à la fois
aristophane il m'a dit que tous ses amis
dans le clan du roi dans le diois sais
pas comment ça on appelle ça se moquer
de lui comment il est avec la même femme
pendant sept ans et donc soit il comme
on me voyait pas puisque j'étais vous
allez entièrement donc certains se
demandent et elle doit être sûrement
belle des autres et non celle de cette
sûrement il est donc qui ne génère que
d'autres se disaient oh elle doit doit
avoir quelque chose des forces
surnaturelles dont on traite on disait
aux trouver tout pour que voilà ce
mariage ne marche pas et je pense que
c'est un peu en fait la raison pour se
prendre une épouse supplémentaire c'est
de dire à sa première femme écoute
chérie tu es très occupé avec les
enfants donc maintenant j'ai besoin
d'une femme plus jeune qui soit moins
occupé avec les enfants ça c'est ceux
qui s'occupent de moi voilà bon seuil
critique pas mais enfin c'est vrai que
c'est une vision qui laisse rêveur même
temps l'idiot tu es pas content viendra
bien séoudiens non c'est vrai qu'il ya
d'intéressant si c'est pas mal comme tp
femmes et les femmes aiment traite de
pda
ha bon
et donc là que tu sais pas réduit donc
et vous partez après c'était la rupture
quoi je voulais plus rentrer way to ta
robe
là je rentrais plus du tout ce que je
faisais j'avais déjà trois enfants
je vais vous faire vous allez voir c'est
la question qui tue est ce que vous
aviez eu à choisir donc entre d'une part
vivre en arabie saoudite cloîtraient
avec vos enfants ou quitter l'arabie
saoudite et vivre sans vos enfants
est-ce que des fois vous vous dites pas
j'aurais mieux fait de rester en arabie
saoudite parce que je serai toujours
avec mes enfants je me dis ça tous les
matins je vous dis ça tous les matins et
tous les matins quand je parle à mes
enfants je leur demande de me pardonner
d'avoir
décidé de partir parce que je ne pouvais
plus être une bonne mère où je pensais
qu'à la fin je vais devenir une mère
folle et mais je sais aujourd'hui ma
force de résistance était telle que
j'aurais pu rester et d'ailleurs mon
fils aîné me dit jusqu'à présent au
moment qui est parti trop tôt pour à vue
merci donc vous dites je ne crois plus à
l'amour c'est quand même grave quand on
vous voit vous êtes jolie vous êtes cris
je vous est cultivée c'est terrible ça
non non parce que je suis très occupé
c'est à dire qu'au moment où je pouvais
croire en l'amour et le au moment où
j'étais en arabie saudite tu pouvais
avoir tous les amants les plus beaux les
plus magnifiques et je faisais rien de
mon temps sauf ont géré la maison des
enfants et s'occuper des enfants
les philippins j'ai dit j'ai passé ma
vie avec des philippins des enfants donc
vous développez si vous voulez vraiment
un désintérêt total
et quand les quand on me pose la
question comment j'ai pu me conserver
physiquement aussi longtemps et bien je
peux vous dire c'est à cause de ça c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle mais il faut pas
noble il faut pas de sexe alors bien se
conserver tandis qu'henri physiquement
et c'est une très mauvaise c'est vérifié
les pierres ils avaient fait la forme
pleine forme ce que vous dites vous
dites moi où je ne me remarierai pas
jamais riche maintenant
non mais c'est terrible quoi jamais
jamais je viens du nombre de mâles
heureux que vous faites très soir-là à
moi aussi j'avais jamais rencontré un
homme dont vous vous dites jamais
j'aimais bien après donc vous partiez à
new york l'abc une expérience aussi pas
très drôle parce que les gens voulaient
profiter de vous vous êtes tombé sur une
bande de parasites on peut dire non oui
c'est un peu le cas de toutes les femmes
je pense seul et il savait qui j'étais
beaucoup plus que moi je le savais donc
j'étais d'une laïcité absolument
inacceptable à mona dix ans alors un
jour vous vendez vos bijoux
gagner 60 à la vente vous rapporte 62
millions de francs en deux heures de
vente vous en donnez d'ailleurs une
grande partie est la fondation pompidou
on y reviendra
ils émettent jamais c'est donc là il est
maître jamais et vous achetez le fossé à
36 millions de francs bateau qui avait
appartenu alain colas et à bernard tapie
et la restauration du phocéa vous coûte
plus cher que prévu ça coûte une
centaine de millions de francs
120 millions ce qui fait quand même le
bateau autour de 150 millions quand même
alors vous vous louez ce bateau et
combien un million de 1 million 5 la
semaine en haute saison il fait un
million deux way la semaine là la haute
saison c'est-à-dire call juillet-août en
méditerranée on peut être à combien sur
ce bateau ah bah non je dis ça il ya des
gens sur nes calcul de direction même si
on est trois mille on peut seulement
3000 on peut les acheter
oui parce que c'est un drapeau anglais
malheureusement peut pas être puisque 12
à 12 donc ça perdu 1 million 2 / 12 mai
2009 à 100 mille balles pour une semaine
par pers ossements waouh
mais tous y compris un bon mois sur elle
non j'avais peur d'être obligé de payer
le 20 août à la haute couture vouloir
laisser coi par an 3 millions par an à
peu près non 6,6 je suis crevé je
collectionne la haute kotto
vous dites on a tous besoin d'une drogue
moi c'est la haute couture ça ne nuit
pas c'est vrai que c'est une drogue qui
nuit passée nuit un peu à votre compte
en banque ce que vous dites mais ça ne
nuit pas il faut travailler plus dur et
faire plus d'argent donc frais mais
c'est vrai vous avez porté votre
première robe à l'âge de 7 ans seulement
moi j'étais un garçon manqué je passais
mon temps à marcher dans les forêts à
lire grimper les arbres j'ai passé mon
temps à être seul et c'est peut-être
cette nature là qui m'a aidée à
surmonter les 20 ans de solitude en
arabie saoudite alors vous dites la
haute couture ne mourra pas tant que je
serai vivante et c'est vrai qu'il
suffirait de 15 femmes comme vous pour
que la haute couture survivent alors en
juillet 99
vous avez fait une exposition à
marseille 120 robe vous en avez 2002
revenant 1140 euros avec plus de 120 sur
le dixième de votre collection au musée
de la mode de marseille ça c'est une
erreur que j'adore c'était une copie de
la robe
coco chanel vous êtes on a eu de très
bonnes clients de la maison la maison
dior et dernièrement il ya eu je dis pas
que c'était un énorme scandale mais
enfin quelque chose d'assez choquant
c'est que john galliano a fait une
collection sdf c'est à dire qu'il a
habillé les collections de haute couture
inspiré des habits de sdf avec des
bouteilles accrochées à la ceinture
enfin et c'est nouveau
pas moi
ap tiger ou
voilà donc c'est la connexion de john
galliano pour dior
alors d'accord vous choquer beaucoup
non moi ça me choque pas moi je trouve
que c'est une expression comme tout
autre c'est une expression artistique
pour la mode vient de la rue depuis
toujours donc pourquoi pas alors vous
donner aux uns vous donner beaucoup
d'argent aux oeuvres caritatives
quand on vous dit pourquoi vous le dites
vous dis je décide de le dire pour mes
enfants parce que vos enfants vous
reproche des fois votre votre sens des
affaires votre indépendance votre
liberté et donc vous vous pensez que
c'est mieux de le dire leur montrer
qu'avec l'argent finalement on peut
faire aussi des choses utiles
d'abord il me reproche mon départ et
puis je ne suis pas avec eux j'adore les
enfants j'adore les meilleurs j'adore
les enfants je vais toujours faire
quelque chose pour les enfants
je compense si vous voulez ce manque en
embrassant prenant les bras d'autres
enfants mais surtout en les aidant et en
les éduquant parce que l'éducation la
culture fait énormément de différences
je pense que si 90 % des enfants en
arabie saoudite sont éduqués de la même
manière que les enfants en france et que
les enfants aux etats unis le monde
serait là bas en tout cas ça serait
beaucoup plus heureux or le 29 février
2000 aura lieu donc une vente à
christie's dont les bénéfices vous les
donnerais à l'atelier des enfants du
centre pompidou à beaubourg que vous
parrainer pour pour trois ans si je
donne aujourd'hui si vous voulez
au musée surtout le pour les enfants de
l'atelier des enfants c'est parce
qu'encore je pense que si j'avais pu moi
même profité de cette culture artistique
pendant 20 ans je pense ça va être
encore une personne beaucoup plus de
plus intéressante que si je vous raconte
ce soir c'est très intéressante
on va regarder des oeuvres d'art que
vous aimez magnéto serge le cyclope m'a
beaucoup intéressé parce que quand
j'étais enfant on me disait toujours
dessine un homme qui te fait peur et
c'était toujours le cyclope pendant
toute ma vie j'ai dessiné un homme avec
un soleil et une seule bouche et quand
je suis arrivé à milly la forêt l'année
dernière j'étais je l'avais vu il ce
cyclope qui était avec moi depuis et
j'étais très intéressé par le travail de
l'esprit très ouvert de l'esprit très
ouvert très avant-garde ailleurs c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle j'ai
quitté un homme si riche pour pouvoir
m'exprimer très bien bien alors moon a
maintenant
benoît xvi vous avez eu des hauts et des
bas on va faire une interview de nandan
vous soyez un truc ici c'est que pendant
le jingle on ne bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui on fait bouger ce que vous préférez
en vous la chose que vous préférez en
vous ma franchi la chose que vous
détestez en vous ma naïveté
le plus grand moment de votre vie la
première enfants que j'ai eus et le pire
quand il était désolé malade quand on
m'a appris qu'il avait la leucémie cité
à paris d'ailleurs ce qui vous plaît le
plus dans la vie
l'océan la mer ce qui nous emmerde le
plus dans la vie des hommes
on n'a aucune chance votre plus gros
coup de frais votre meilleure affaire
que j'ai jamais faite
on tend coca cola est arrivé à ryad
coca cola vous savez été interdite à
ryad parce qu'ils avaient fabriqués en
israël tout ce qui est fabriqué en
israël est interdite en arabie saoudite
et du coup je me lève un matin je lis le
journal et je vois que coca cola est
arrivé en arabie saoudite par
l'intermédiaire d'un ami à monex à mon
ex mari
alors j'appelle cette amie bien sûr je
suis fan depuis rien ils ne m'écoutent
pas évident gouna tu te débrouilles
ailleurs alors j'appelle un autre avis
un libanais qui habite en amérique je
lui dit tu peux s'il te plaît m'acheter
des actions tant que tu peux émettre
jusqu'à quand tu peux m j'ai dit jusqu'à
presque 500 mille dollars en trois mois
c'est devenu un million cinq cent mille
dollars
mais voilà et 300 pour ça
votre plus grosse paire que c'est quoi
une mauvaise affaire
epson à mon divorce
si vous fait le plus rire qui me fait
rire vous c'est gentil de me renier pas
les âmes si vous faites moi rire
la maladie et la souffrance des enfants
si vous avez plus sexy en vous et de
moins sexy mes muscles avant des émules
à ses provinces clés pour être faites
vous faites trop de sport trop pourquoi
jusqu'à deux heures par jour basse
avaient assez attachant tous les matins
et des téléphones bandai acheter bon
dieu merci on a vu mieux les corrections
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus